tonight allows people a release
for all the hatred and violence if they
keep up inside them why don't you guys
kill someone tonight
because we don't feel the need to johnny
the first purge film
was incredibly special to me and uh to
the company because
it was our fourth low budget high
concept movie we did paranormal then
it's been insidious then sinister
and then the purge and i'm often asked
what our favorite movie
we've ever produced is and of course
like a child i like
different ones for different reasons but
i can say that the best experience i had
ever was the first purge not the first
purge
that's the name of a subsequent movie in
the title but the purge movie the
original birds movie
and that was because i've been going
around saying you know there's really
something to this new system of making
movies and everyone thought that that
was not true
and everyone thought i didn't know what
i was talking about and when we released
the purge it took four times
but when we released the purge that was
the first time that people said wait
maybe this uh
maybe this plum house company can can
attack movie making in a different way
and
make good movies and and make
interesting movies and edgy movies and
subversive movies
and so the purge the original purge
movie was really a turning point
for me personally for the company and um
it's one of the reasons i really love
the franchise the great the crazy idea
for purge night actually came from my
wife thought prefaces with that she's an
incredibly smart sweet woman she's a
doctor and
she loves people you know but we were
driving in brooklyn and there was a road
rage incident where i was driving with
her and
we were cut off by this drunk driver i
got up we were there was fists
thrown and chaos and cops and and she
said to me
in anger she said oh i wish we all got
one free one a year
and i knew what she meant and it was
quite dark and like oh honey that's a
pretty pretty crazy thing to say but it
stayed with me it stayed with me for
years and then
coupling that with i was living in paris
for all quite a long time um
posting my first film and i stayed after
that no parisians i know had any guns
literally i didn't meet a parisian who
had a gun i'd say seven out of the ten
americans i knew had a gun so i just
started really thinking about the
relationship between americans and guns
violence and and my wife's kind of
conceit this crazy thing she said came
into my head
and and i i just one day woke up with
this idea for a new national holiday
just remember all the good the purge
does we'll be fine just like always no
worries okay
at the time uh it was a whole different
management team in place
uh at universal and there was a lot of
nervousness on the studio's part and we
actually had to push the release date
it was weird we got some notes strange
notes early on from different
entities you know we give it to various
financiers and they were coming back
with notes saying you have to say no
nuclear weapons
like oh okay and then we got a lot of
notes saying you have to um
take children off the purge meaning no
children can be killed during the purge
the original movie uh i showed to some
some journalist friends early on and
they both got it you know they really
they really got the movie they saw the
movie and they helped
make everyone feel more comfortable
about releasing the film
but that's that you know that was that
that was the thing that that
not everyone understood originally these
are cautionary tales you know
we the idea is that america has this uh
insane relationship to guns and we were
kind of putting a spotlight on that
the nihilism of the idea is so grand
that i think it people's minds go to
very dark places understandably and they
want rules to relegate their dark their
own darkness that they think of
our sequels we invest a little bit more
money in because we have a concept that
we know
um audiences like so what was really fun
on the second purge movie
was to get to see what it was like
outside the house
the first movie you only experienced the
purge through
this family's experience inside we never
got to see what happened
outside and what happened with the
purgers what they were really doing
so what was really fun about the second
movie and the subsequent movies was to
you know take our cameras outside at
night during the purge
and seeing you know the insanity that
that went on out there
in shooting of the first film i began to
realize the conceit of the purge
was so big that i started to become
afraid that the audience would be very
sad to be inside one house and we did
get that reaction on purge one there
were people who were like wait i want to
see what's happening in the streets of
america
so in the conception of the future films
i immediately in the middle of shooting
purge one
i began to say okay we need to open this
up we're gonna have to broaden this
you have to go higher in the budget and
we're going to have to hit the streets
of america to show
what purging looks like out inside the
streets and cities of america
in creating the film yet there's always
been these things that happen over the
years that people always come to me
saying how did you know
that hillary was going to be the the
nominee and yeah there were certain
things that happened along the way that
we kind of predated in the film
and you know like as jason blum and
sebastian always say i'm kind of the
nostradamus of the horror
purge world and that whatever i write
comes true and i wish that weren't true
i wish they didn't have any kind of
resonance in in the modern world i
weren't i wish they weren't mirroring
society i wish we lived in a very
harmonious place with no
discord and the purge films had no
relevance he's incredible
at somehow predicting what's going to
happen so i always said about that movie
uh we got for the movie businesses we
very we got very lucky uh as a country
maybe less so
but it was by chance there's no way
james could have known what was gonna
what was gonna take place but each movie
that he's written
has has somehow you know seen into the
future and and foretold things to come
[Music]
i think what shapes the purge movies is
is the society around us what the
audience that reacted the most i'd say
to me
when i would go to comic con was the
black and latino audiences was great
fans of the series
so some people did ask me along the way
did they dictate where we were going
for me the the series always had the
underpinnings we were always you know
trying to sneaky socio-political ideas
into the series so we were always
dealing with racial issues
income disparity and it seemed to be the
appropriate places to go so it probably
was the natural way to go and then i was
kind of pushed by the audience reaction
i think it all happened simultaneously
i think artists should take their
experience in the world
and pack it into really cool stories in
our case scary
the scariest horror movies you could
make and i think that's what james does
[Music]
i think what's new about the forever
purge is that it takes this idea that
there's
that the purge happens in a contained
time and blows it out the window
there's chaos forever and all the rules
are broken
the initial conceit for purge five is
the strangest thing so
i initially wanted to do a love story
and i know that freaked everybody out i
had this image of this couple
coming from mexico immigrating into
america were madly in love passionately
in love
yet they had two different takes on what
the american dream was does it still
exist if it still exists who is it who
does it exist for
at the time this is two and a half years
ago the border crisis was in the
headlines everywhere that's what we were
dealing with in our country so that's
informing everything i'm writing
but i knew i needed more i knew i needed
to flip the concept upside down because
i was like
we can't go back to a 12-hour purge
we've done that
people are going to get mad at that
that's what set everything in motion
then we were able to combine the kind of
love story and this
exploration of the american dream with
this very horrific
flipping of the purge that it just keeps
going because that's what the concede
was oh
put all the put all the violence of the
year into one 12-hour period and
everything will be peaceful for the rest
of the year
you know and then we realize in page
five that that's an impossible thing you
cannot contain
hatred and violence in that way it just
becomes more of a virus that spreads
as a kind of comment on the american
dream i think i think all
the movies to a certain degree say the
american dream is not all that it's
cracked up to be
and that's who especially you know in
the last
year or 18 months it's something that a
lot of people are talking about and
thinking about that the american dream
as advertised may not be uh
exactly the reality of the american
dream
there's no crime anymore anything goes
in the initial conceit of all the ideas
i'd like to always incorporate
specifically in that third act some kind
of hope
some kind of either i would say we try
to end a purge movie where they're
saving a life and not taking a life
whether that be the edwin hodge
character in purge one where they decide
we're not going to kill this man for
saving our family part two the leo
character decides i'm not gonna kill the
drunk driver who killed my kid part
three they decide not to kill the
minister even though he's an evil man so
there's a constant decision to save
elon is saving the family in part four
and now in part five there's the hope
of some kind of uh the josh lucas
character evolving into something more
harmonious his thoughts
it is definitely designed to end in some
place of hope and harmony
even in the middle of this extremely
nihilistic concept so we're hoping the
audience feels that harmony is starting
even amidst all the chaos around them
and i'm hoping that infuses some hope
into the audience
speak
does this translate i think it's great
to see a movie in a movie theater i
don't know if i would use the word
important but i would definitely say
it's much more fun
particularly our movies are just way
way more effective if you want to be
scared you want to be the most scared
you can be
at one of our movies the way to see the
movie and the only way to see the movie
is in a movie theater and that
sucks you into what's going on much more
profoundly than at home
and when you are sucked in the ability
of
for the movie to frighten uh is
heightened tremendously
the purge series has meant a lot to
blumhouse in that it's almost the
longest running like paranormal activity
we've we've got uh we've got a couple
more movies but it's almost the longest
running franchise that we have
and uh is this the end you know i never
i hope not i hope not i would never say
never uh
everyone's threatening this is the last
movie but you know my job is to make
that not true
so hopefully i'll prevail
[Music]
you